hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from the family co-op
internal in 2019 the game comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber
petrovin Eska so thank you for that and
the game is great but it leads to an
even greater achievement we're gonna
talk about that a bit more after we
check out the game it's again between
Portuguese Grand Master Luis Gallego and
Armenian Grandmaster Karen Gregorian and
it's a also a really interesting fact
that the Ligurian comes into this game
it's a game from the final round from
round nine as already the winner of the
tournament he won eight previous games
so now he's eight in eight and he faces
well the the Portuguese Grandmaster as
his final test so let's see the game at
the e4 is already on the board so let's
just check it out we have c5 in
Gregorian goes for the Sicilian defense
we have knife to f3 d6 and now c3 the
ala pin variation preparing d4 not going
for d4 immediately knife to f6 and now
Bishop to b5 check with the shop to d7
now we have a trade here Bishop captures
Queen captures and now d3 so white
keeping it slow so the same he gives the
center and now e six by black preparing
Bishop to e7 with castles by white and
now Bishop to e7 and there are a couple
of moves that have been played in this
position Knight bTW 2 has been played
here Rupe to e1 has been played here
Gallego already had this position in
2000 against Hill you olufsen and played
a three here the game ended in a draw
also David Bronstein in 1946 played
Quinta e 2 here here he was able to win
a very nice game with this move but
Bishop to g5 the move Gallego plays now
in this position is a new move and
already as of move 8 we have a
completely new game so let's see how the
game continues we have h6 challenging
the bishop and already Bishop captures
on f6 which is very very interesting as
white already gave up both of the
bishops and it's interesting to see
where the compensation is for this with
beef or seek a person d4 see captors on
d4 and black now castles with Knight the
c3 Knight to c6 and now
to rook the c1 of course developing the
roof to a nice open C file and already
with d5 from black and you will often
hear if black is able to execute d5 in
the Sicilian then he's doing very well
ie five is not a problem here
it would be a problem if white had a
light square bishop to put on this
beautiful diagonal but he doesn't as he
gave it away Bishop d7 and black just
continues there's there's no good way
white can take advantage of this
so after d5 we have he captures on d5 e
capture Sun B 5 and now Queen to d3 just
developing the Queen connecting groups
and rook f e8 black also puts a look on
a nice open e file with rook F to D 1
and now comes rook the e6 already black
is ready to double up Brooks and E on
the e-file with g3 by white and now
comes Bishop to g5 so what do you do
here if you capture here you could
capture it's not a problem but then
black might be able to start an attack
against the White King maybe some rook
h6 followed by Quint h3 ideas are
possible now that the g3 has been played
so why decides against this first we
have looked back to b1 as the group was
under attack here and now comes Knight
to be for attacking the Queen and
pressuring the a to pawn we have Queen
to b5 offering a queen trade and the
black of course is very happy to oblige
with Queen captures and Knight captures
and now rook to d8 not allowing rook to
c7 to come with a nice fork against the
rook
so rook to d8 also additional defense to
the d5 pawn in here black says ok you
capture my pawn I'm gonna capture your
pawn it's not a problem so whitey
decides against this with Knight to c3
defending the a to pawn and now Bush
should be back to f6 controlling the
knight on f3 and also putting pressure
on the d4 pawn we have rugby back to c1
and now g5 preparing g4 to kick away the
night with h3 preventing this and black
really wants to push g4 so h5 now what
do you play here King to g2 by white and
now g4 and okay we have h characters H
captures and now comes Knight to e5 and
here black decides to capture with
bushel characters
d captures and now a nice decision to
make what do you play here do recap 3
immediately or do you maybe play
something else here capturing
immediately runs into rook to d4 rugby
for with an attack against the night
here and then after you move the knight
you get the rook captures with check and
you don't really gain anything here
instead of capturing right away we have
sorry about that
whoa we have d4 attacking the knight and
what do you do now
the knight is under attack with Knights
to e4 and now ok you capture the night
but you still don't get to keep your g4
pawn sorry capture the pawn with Knight
to f6 width check King g7 attacking the
knight and now comes the Knight captures
on g4 and now rook to g5 it's a bit
different from the language just shown
as it's now black was calling the shots
with Knights to h2 preparing to bring
the knight back to f3 and now finally
Knight captures on a2 and here white
should have gone for rook to c7 just a
nice move threatening to win BB 7 point
after let's say black pushes d3 we have
route captures here and then a5 the pawn
on e5 is now nicely protected if Knight
f3 attacking the rook rook the c5 and
still black black is maybe a bit better
but still it's hard to imagine that you
could actually push this all the way
here rook to a1 was played with an
attack against the night here but now
black has Rupe to a5 so the knight is
defended and now Knight to f3 with a
double attack against the d4 pawn so
naturally black advance is the pawn we
have d3 and now rook the d2 here white
White's idea is to just block the pawn
here and also prepare b3 after b3 is
played then both of the rooks will be
attacking the knight here and the rook
on a5 is undefended so b6 you have to
play this the rook has to be defended
with b3 by white but now it's not a
problem for black because well pause the
video here and try to find how to hide
you save the night here I'll give you a
couple of seconds so just a normal
decision in the endgame you're probably
gonna
you don't guess this one correctly not
guess I mean calculate everything out so
the idea isn't nice to be for this is
the correct move because if you go
Knight to c3 then after this capture
captures pawn captures white has Mighty
One and you lose the d3 pawn there's no
way to defend it for black so here after
be three Knights 2d nice to be forest
played and now we have rook captures on
a5 b captures on a5 and now you don't
have night to e1 as already the knight
and the rook are guarding the pond so
look back to d1 here white wants to go
rook to e1 to start cleaning up the
doubled a pawns with King to f6 and now
rook to a-1 going after the pawn trying
maybe the trick white well not really to
trick but if y if black continues to
push here for example 22 then ruled e1
just wins the pawn there's no way to
defend it so we have night the c2
attacking and the rook here and here
blacks that's a very nice trap here if
white actually captured the pawn rook
captures an a5 do you see what black had
in mind once again pause the video and
try to find it this very nice idea that
the Gregorian had in this position I'll
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
Forker with a knight and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
Knights the e1 check and here you can
see it's check and the knight is under
attack
the problem is your night is not
defended but it's not a problem if you
move the King you lose the knight on f3
but what happens if white captures if
white captures then d2 happens we get
the same idea that we've shown in the
previous video in the last perverse
couple Blanca game you can prevent both
d1 Queen and D captures on e 1 so if the
knight moves you just grab a queen and
if you don't do well you will lose the
night so here white could play rook e1
but still you're gonna get a queen and
here it's just a rock against the night
and it's not even close yes you do have
a your upper pawn is white but still
after the knight moves you're just gonna
attack the pawn pawn before rook attacks
pawn and next move you're gonna play
rugby - white will have to move the pawn
and you lose the B for point
so it's not even close after night the
c2 we have looked to d1 just keeping
around the d3 pawn and now King to f5
and here the idea is to prevent the
black King from entering the position
and you do this by playing rook to h1
the idea is after eg for you can play
rook to h4 and you don't have a square
for the King you have to you have to go
back with the King and then what the
game continues you can go maybe rook
here you can go maybe rook checks here
maybe try and pick up this pawn but in
the game Knights the d2 happened and
here white way white made a critical
mistake of allowing the King from
advancing with King to e5 which was not
possible when the night was an f3 so
this is exactly what the big Orion does
with King to e5 and now Knight back to
f3 check with King to e4 and now rook to
h1 so it's the same position only it's
now white to move so if it was white to
move we would have the same position but
here it's not white to move it's black
to move and black makes room for the
King while advancing the pawn d2 and
again what what sorcery is this white
just goes route back to d1 and it seems
black blundered upon or you know did
black actually blunder a pawn so feel
free
the once again pause the video here and
try to find what was black's idea here
otherwise you're just gonna lose a very
nice pass pawn while I give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations for the
second time you are an even greater for
Kerr with the night and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
Knights the e3 check not only check but
also you're threatening to pick up the
rook so there's no I don't move but to
capture the night this is what Gallego
played with F captures on e3 and now
King captures on e3 so again you have to
decide what to do here you have to
prevent Kingi - if King E - then it's
all over
you can't play King to f1 because the
knight on f3 hands so Gallego here goes
the night the g1 but now black finds
another very nice way look the c8 the
threat is the rook to c1 and here we
have looked
f1 trying to meet rook to c1 with rook
to F if rook to c1 now then roof to f3
check could pose some problems for black
but not really if King to D 492 check
after the King moves you still can't
capture the rook because black just gets
another Queen so even this was not
possible but black does not allow that
rook the c2 now threatening d1 with
check a discovered check from the rook
King to h3 and now rook to c1 and now
it's a bit different we look after each
ech kink the e4 and now rook f4 check
like we said if you try something with
the knight doesn't work so look a four
check King to d3 and now you no longer
have any good options look to f3 check
with king - see - and here white played
nice the ITO trying to maybe get this
idea that if the pawn Queens then you
can get rook c3 check but still there's
nothing to actually prevent white from
instantly losing after king b2 and rook
captures here black can even give up a
queen for example Queen captures night
capture screen captures and the King and
pawn and game is completely winning for
black to quickly demonstrate if king g4
you're just gonna pick up this pawn king
a5 King captures and this point is much
faster because this point still can't
even start marching forward you have to
first clear the the f7 pawn and black is
just much faster so here after 92 black
doesn't even allow that good accordion
just place rook to h1 and it was in this
position that Louise Gallego resigned
the game as if there is nothing more to
do here once you move the King by taking
g2 you're gonna play d1 Queen now and
now there is nothing more to do
checkmate is soon to follow so amazing
feat by Armenian Grandmaster occurring
Gregorian just so I don't forget here
are the standings of the tournament the
first you know 1010 people in the
standings you can see that caron
gregorian has a hundred percent
victories nine points a point and a half
ahead of canadian Grandmaster Kevin's
bracket you all know the old saying
never Google
Kevin's private images and there we have
it rating performance 30 103 which I to
my knowledge is a world record in rating
performance which is just insane 9.0 the
biggest one so far we have here the
final standings of the 2014 sinful cup
were Fabiana Caruana destroyed the field
with eight and a half out of nine but he
his rating performance was as you can
see there 3098 so gregorian topped that
by by a margin of five points which is
really insane and okay you could argue
that Cara's opponents were well
definitely were much stronger but but
still our record is a record well you
know you could say that I don't know but
Bobby Fischer beating time on of and
Larsen 12 to 0 will not equal such
saturating performance but as the
ratings were much lower in those days
but still that performance the it in my
opinion has not been matched to date but
um I think Carlson had a like like a
thirty one hundred and something during
the sory 2014 but there was a blitz
tournament so this doesn't count as this
is a classical event so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it
congratulations to Karen Gregorian on
achieving this beautiful record and also
I would I would like to thank you once
again Pedro finesse Co for suggesting
this very nice game as it's impossible
to follow all of the tournaments so very
happy about that
that's why I introduced hashtag
suggestion for you to use in the
comments as I will be even though okay
this game was suggested to me via
Instagram but still you know without
your suggestions this channel would not
be as rich in content as it is so say
thank you all for that but yeah also I
would like to thank bill Daniel
Andres huasos Chris Picard Majid Joe
Barry and John Andrew Williams for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the couple
a saga we are on we are nearing the end
of the long saga checking up in your
nice suggestion such as this one and as
always checking up what's you new in the
chess world thank you all and I will see
you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day